you look tired me hey guys it is Tuesday
here on its grace and you shouldn't
Soviet talk back to you segment however
I won't lie to you guys I've done so so
many times in the past I'm really tired
we just got back from shooting a bunch
of hand USA episodes and it was so much
fun so much fun to the point that I
don't even remember so first of all if
you have not won over and watched a USA
which is maimry hearts you deserve a
drink main town a nice travel web series
over on youtube.com slash astronauts
wanted TV you should because it's us
going around the United States and
charmingly offending everyone wear a
salad video by yes we've been traveling
so much for this show and I just got
back to Los Angeles I'm only here for
day or two I don't even know and then we
go back on the road for more hey USA I'm
really just so tired right now and the
idea of trying to make a video that is
to the best of my ability seems um seems
really difficult right now sometimes
just don't feel like yourself when
you're overly tired you feel like you've
become I just would rather take some
time off and try to force feed you
porsche because one thing i've learned
on hey USA is like don't eat horse [ __ ]
there's like a lot of other things that
you can eat in the world for instance i
ate corn at an IHOP at 11pm last night
that's also something you shouldn't eat
so I will be taking the rest of this
week off for making videos I apologize
if that's really upset
running you there are other things in
the world that can occupy your time
please don't forget about me
me
yeah and then I'm be back next week
happier healthier more creative
hopefully than ever
after that August first is the start of
another announcement there's some other
fun things and Carol I tell you about so
why is white try and even tease you with
any of this oh there will be a nun mmm i
can't i have to wait till tomorrow to
make this announcement it was a really
fun thing coming and i will post a video
about it somewhere on my social medias
tomorrow that I think you are really
going to enjoy
I don't know did it dad to dad to death